RICHARD DOLAN: November, 1944.
One of the early
interesting Foo Fire reports
comes from the 415th
Night Fighter Squadron.
They're flying missions
over northeastern France.
That's not far from Germany.
And this is still
in Nazi-occupied
part of France where you've
got a number of lights--
eight, 10, 12 lights coming
in on the left of the aircraft
group that are apparently
maneuvering in a very
unusual way, and
then just take off
at a very high rate of speed.
This type of thing was
reported many times.
JACQUES VALLEE: The pilots often
described these objects were
sort of fuzzy
lights that could be
a plasma light that would
come up from the ground
towards the airplane.
And we know that
now, because there
have been re-investigations
of all the flights.
At the time, of course,
there was no Air Force.
There was the Army Air Force.
They were taking reports
from pilots very,
very seriously, because if
there was a new German weapon,
all the pilots needed
to know about it
and they needed to think
about evasive action.
These objects were called
different things at the time
before they got a name,
and the name that stuck
was Foo Fighters.
And it comes from a comic strip
that was popular at the time
called "Smokey Stover."
And he had a saying which
was, where there's a Foo,
there's fire.
The US government has never
offered an explanation
for the Foo Fighters.
We know that the OSS, which
was the precursor of the CIA,
investigated.
We know that British
intelligence investigated this.
And we don't have conclusions.
Dr. Hynek, he was
just as puzzled as,
I think, anybody else.
My father would refer
to the Foo Fighters
as sort of an
example of something
that they're something
fairly serious
that we should look into.
Or, you know, it's worthy
of investigation, at least
it supports the
idea that there's
something going on that
we don't understand
or we should look into.